oh air hockey basketball we could play
that
oh
whack-a-mole brothers or sisters three
brothers really mm-hmm two are in the
marines one's a cup vegetarian
no i love meat
what's your blood type oh negative
universal donor universal donor
michael oh god i don't wait come on i
wanted to talk to you about the
downsizing there's no downsizing
what
oh nothing
jim's been looking at me kind of
a lot all week
i would be creeped out by it but it's
nothing compared to the way michael
looks at me
dwight's room key
and dwight's room
what can i say old habits
die hard d
oh my god dwight got a hooker
[Music]
butt licker our prices have never been
lowered
you've reached the voicemail of dwight
kurt schrute please leave
oh man what do you think happened
oh looks like jim got mixed up with some
bad apples
oh no no no no
it wasn't me
we gotta find the wanda at that alcohol
club oh
i am so scared
when people don't label their personal
food
oh my god uh oh my god fire oh fire oh
my goodness what's the procedure
oh my god what is that the fire's
shooting at us
well i hope it was worth it cause i'm
gonna take it apart in about five
minutes i think it'll take you a little
bit longer than that really if i can
skin a mule deer in less than 10 minutes
i ought to be able to cut my
is there another meeting schedule that i
was gonna do the blackberry tutorial in
here michael told us to wait in here we
don't know why
uh-oh okay okay nobody panic
excuse me everyone sacks
hey pickles merry christmas open
immediately
love swiss cheese
stop
too late if i was the real scranton
strangler you'd be so strangled by now
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
seriously you're gonna send me back
uh yeah that's the safest part of a car
in the event of a crash driver always
protects his side first
after you sir no thank you i never let
anyone walk behind me seven out of ten
attacks are from the rear okay well that
still leaves a 30 chance that i'll
attack you from the front uh yeah but
it'll be easier to stop i can always
block the blow or i can counter it with
it
what the hell was that ding dong
who's there kgb
do i get the door i'm not answering
answer them down no way it's the key
thing though i'm not answering that yes
you're going to answer i'm not going to
answer i'm not going to enter into kgb
the kgb will fit for no one
like a few years down the road cece says
mom
there's a ghost in my closet now you say
one of two things one you're just having
a bad dream or two let's go see what it
wants i'm not gonna freak her out jim
okay i'm not gonna lie to her either oh
come on when i was a boy
there was an empty house
just up the hill from my families it was
rumored a man committed suicide there
after being possessed by the devil
one day a young woman lydia
moved into the house with her infant
child that very night lydia was awakened
by a loud
heinous hissing sound
she walked to the nursery and there in
baby's crib was a snake
wrapped around baby's neck
squeezing tighter and tighter oh my
goodness the crib was full of dirt
babies struggled to free itself from
underneath reaching and clawing gasping
for air
embalmed bodies rose from their
sarcophagi
lurching toward baby
for they were mummies no
amongst them was a man
tall
slim jim
almost instinctively she turned to her
husband oh wait she thought
i don't have a husband
for lydia and her husband had had an
argument
one they couldn't get past each night
they slept one inch farther apart until
one night lydia left
it was about this time she lost herself
an imaginary worlds
she had quit the book club the choir
citing something about their high
expectations
her lips slowly grew together from
disuse every time she wanted to act and
didn't another part of her face hardened
until it was stone
and that fevered night
she rushed to the nursery and threw open
the door
baby are you okay
baby sat up slowly
turned to mother
and said
i'm fine [ __ ]
i'm fine
you